last question for you the big one in the
room what would it take for you to run
for president in 2020 and if not then
2020 for my family saying yes otherwise
I would have already done it you know I
haven't ruled it out because everybody
asked me and it's like well why don't
you just say yes or no because so much
crazy [ __ ] is happening you know wrong
person gets sick right everything
changes
you know we don't but people are afraid
to go out or the economy gets worse
everything changes you know and I think
what's really missing is no one
understands technology and technology
out of the candidates and even our
senior politicians and you know our most
powerful powerful politicians they don't
get tech at all and yet Tech is going to
drive America 2.0 more than anything we
could ever otherwise do you know whether
it's robotics AI precision medicine all
these things are going to be the
foundation to our economy going forward
and nobody who's running and nobody
who's behind those people who running or
in positions of power get any of that
and that's the real problem
part of I think what's really
interesting is the one thing that Donald
Trump definitely did in his presidential
run was he kind of changed the rules of
the game right certain things that were
taboo before now are cool don't you see
that with the Andrew yang type campaign
you said with Mike Bloomberg on memes
and just a lot of things have changed I
guess what's the PlayBook that you pull
out like I say for 2020 and you got a
couple of months and what do you do to
even have a shot I mean I talk about
America 2.0 I talk about the fact that I
hate both parties to talk about the fact
that literally I would I would try to
get rid of both parties they serve no
purpose I talk about the fact that you
know Supreme Court I would balance it I
would make sure that there's a
Republican and independent a Democrat
repeat right that when it comes to
appointing people for positions I don't
care what their political affiliation is
I'd appoint the best person you know and
most likely it turns into a balance
again with independence those are the
types of things where people just say
you know what just put the best person
in I don't care if you're a Republican
or Democrat I'm happy to work with you
you know
Speaker of the House I wouldn't put a
politician in there you know you don't
have to be an elected official to be the
Speaker of the House I would go out
there and find somebody from the outside
who can add some balance you know
there's just so many different things
that that just reach wreck that allow me
to reject traditional
politics that nobody who's a politician
is able to do and so I think that's what
creates a lot of opportunity for me I
got to speak for a lot of people if you
went in and said our whole our whole
mission here is to get rid of the
politicians and get you know business
leaders and entrepreneurs in here I
think you'd have a pretty big following
and not just entrepreneurs right I mean
look there's people who understand
government who aren't politicians right
the fact that you have theirs they come
an organization that give a lot of money
to a called competitive democracy org
and their whole mission in life is to
help independents get on ballots because
the Republicans and Democrats do
everything possible to keep nan Republic
or Democratic candidates off the ballot
so we don't get the best candidates and
so those are the types of things that if
I walked in I would say all that shit's
out the door right
politics are gone right it's about doing
what's right for the American people
that's that would be me right America
2.0 from a political and economic and
technological perspective where we put
people first you jack up the minimum
wage if a company has people that are on
public assistance you find out why and
you solve that problem there's just a
lot of things where we can put people
first and really propel this country to
do better things when we get on the
other side of this yeah it'd be hell of
a story to tell my head but listen to be
Elvis story to go from sleeping on the
floor in the apartment to dancing naked
bein a billionaire and eventually the
Oval Office give you all the credit that
accelerated alright listen mark I really
appreciate it just keep doing you man it
we're all wrong cheers John and we're
enjoying it so thanks so much for doing
this I appreciate it thanks for having
me on